i had a few questions about tim dillon
uh let me let me say i think there's a
podcast coming out with tim dillon on um
the tim dillon show
on monday so he said that he came down
to my place we recorded a conversation
together
and i'm a huge fan of his i did a
podcast he was on on the on this on the
lex whatever podcast that i do i really
enjoyed that
i think
the reason i wanted to do a conversation
with him so first of all he's a friend
he's somebody who inspires me i disagree
with him obviously on a lot of things
but
he
masterfully puts my and ego in check and
the ego of uh
a ton of people
the powerful
um
and that's really important and to do it
with grace with uh with mastery of
comedy is it's just it's really good i i
in general
like like i said on the podcast smart
people that act silly versus silly
people that act smart and um
again i don't know
if i'm smart but i will always err on
the side of the silly and to me
just
being silly
not taking myself seriously not ever
taking myself seriously being able to
take a joke is essential for um
to see clearly through the fog
of
all the uncertainty that is around us
it's so easy to delude yourself to think
you really understand things
that you can see the truth i you have to
have humility that you will never be in
possession of the truth you can only get
closer and closer and that humility to
me is an essential element of that so
the moment you start taking yourself
seriously you start liking the sound of
your own voice as i say on that
on a freaking live stream
the moment you start to fall in love
with yourself in a way that just deludes
you is
uh the moment you become arrogant and
are no longer to be able to discover the
truth again tim dillon is essential for
that he uh i mean he was pretty he's
pretty rough on me in a few spots i'm
sure people are gonna
make fun of me of the silly things i
said on there but uh i deserve it all i
will always deserve it and uh
bring it on internet that's why i love
the
internet whole truth to power
and
i will always err on the side of silly
in fact one of the things that i've been
able to do
more and more lately and one of the
things that elon inspires me to do is be
silly don't take yourself or the world
seriously laugh
laugh at the whole thing at the whole
absurdity of it it'll be over before you
know it
[ __ ] it's gonna be over before you know
it
who is your favorite comedian
am johnson asks who is your favorite
comedian
uh oh this is yeah
sergey says
it's on topic
um
i have so many obviously you don't want
to pick
each one
has
uh
i just love comedy there's so many
amazing it's really unfair so i can pick
a favorite book i can pick a favorite
song even
be tough but i could do it with
comedians i really it's very difficult
so obviously since i'm appearing on tim
dillon's show he is by far the greatest
comedian of all time
the great so we're really saying who's
the number two
because by far tim dillon is the
greatest comedian of all time
and the most valuable person of all time
is ben his producer tim dillon does zero
work contributes nothing to the show
really the most important person
ever arguably so you have gandhi and so
on but above that is ben the producer
for the tim dillon show
aside from that obviously joe rogan has
been a huge inspiration to me in a
million ways and i've talked about it
uh
endlessly
uh mitch hedberg in terms of one-liners
just
[ __ ] genius just just and we lose him
too early
i'm gonna get emotional here uh
louis ck just like
um
the dark humor of louis ck unparalleled
like i just uh
just i mean it reminds me of the russian
humor it's it's the darkness but done so
masterfully that it brings out like
somehow an optimism
um
the mark norman is actually an example
of somebody like that i i we just had a
podcast together he's he's got that
mitch hedberg e vibe but he goes even
darker which i love
um yeah and i think uh norman mcdonald
somebody um
so there's like stand-up comedy and
there's
what those stand-up comics do outside of
that because you can't just take in one
like norman mcdonald's just a genius
the
somebody actually made a comment about
the michael malus conversation about
norman donald maybe i can try to find
the quote he tweeted this in 2018
um
god damn it like
just the the grace with which he left
this world telling no one
the genius
anyway he tweeted uh
the idiot sees the world as good versus
evil the cynic sees the world as evil
versus evil
the truth that no one seems able to see
is that the world is and always has been
a battle of good versus good
norm mcdonald ladies and gentlemen
you